okay hi everyone welcome to another wolf
language design review part of our
incremental language development
series
and we have a few topics
underlighted
yes so this is a new symbol for the next
Wolfram language version
um it actually came up in LCC discussion
but we implemented it and wanted to look
at it here and coincidentally that
agenda item is underlighted itself so we
will be adding that to the spelling
dictionary but I was a little tickled by
it um so there's a futurized ref page
there's an implementation
um that's in the builds now but the the
latest builds are still running so the
initialization section uh at the bottom
of this section will make it work in
this notebook for you
um
I don't quite understand the uh I mean
this is like an era look looking thing
so does it have does under lighted have
different a second argument that
determines how the under lighting is
happening yep so by default color yeah
it has the color
so by default it uses the same
underlining code we have here who's do
we have people from the front end team
here
we didn't specifically bring anyone in
um since we'd already gone over this in
LCC but we had we decided that this I
mean because to me it's like this era
squiggle
I mean I don't know whether that's the
standard meaning of the term under
lighting
well that's the name of the font
variation right so
with a squiggle or with just a
it it's the option right it's you know
do you know style of food comma font
variations goes to I think it's under
light goes to you know red or something
does the so wait a minute who who made
up that term the point being that under
lighted is not the same thing that's
underlined
correct right
but highlighted is
it's lit and I mean you know if I go
look up under light on the web it's all
about
um
you know things that aren't bright
enough or putting lights underneath
um
I mean it just doesn't there's not a
single thing I'm seeing in pages and
Pages here it's all about you know
chandeliers with under lighting
under light Angler
some kind of um
where did this word come from for us
that came from the LCC meeting
well it came from I mean it came from
the name of the font variation now if if
and you did not object to it previously
so we didn't think this would be
something we needed to talk to us well I
mean if the first place we want us to
discuss it we can I I guess because I
think it's tomorrow
let me just look at something here so
um what I'm seeing in my archive
is was introduced by us in 2016 in in
internal discussions
okay
um
but it just seems to have just appeared
there
it mostly seems to be in particular
progress reports
I mean I think John fultz may have
invented this
it's entirely possible
um
well let's look at the design
independent of the name
okay
I mean it's an interesting name I'm just
not sure it's correct
okay so you've got a color there
yeah see I don't quite understand I mean
when we have like overscript for example
overscript takes the second argument
that is the actual thing that you will
overscript with
right because this is they font
variation this is not a thing
well that's why it has an ed at the end
[Music]
um
yeah I mean the original context of
where this came up and where it was
proposed was looking at the different
font variations that exist in Style by
the way this is so wrong what happens
here this should by default be a
spanning character surely
uh not uh
I believe it wants to be a normal Dash
not a
uh not the not an underscore
um
oh
nope okay one well
uh all right maybe there's a little
buglet there but there is something that
should work there
is over bar better
to uh
well okay so you're saying
overboard
that's better
but look at the pathetic documentation
of overscript
yet another example of this
what what makes it pathetic that's only
one example it doesn't show you how to
use the spanning character stuff or
anything
and where's the linked over bar
um okay so somebody should add that
I can pass that along as the first link
it's very badly documented
okay okay yeah so that's at the Box
level if you did an overscript box that
yeah I mean if you look at the boxes of
Over Bar it's over a square box of X
comma underscore so at the Box level but
I guess okay so something went wrong and
who knows what happened with the
overscript thing that's a separate
discussion maybe for an LCC meeting
but right now the issue here is
this is a Pure Color
I mean
you know the more consistency because
it's like it's like small caps I mean
right there there isn't Mo there aren't
multiple things that can be done here
this is specifically to get you wanted a
function to give you a way to do the
squiggly lines that you get from I
understand I understand but those
squigglies
are not if I understand correctly
uh
the that thing
oh
so this
I'm so confused here
okay if I were to say Style
of text comma bold
right so this this is one of the
questions of whether it should be
preserved on input or not
so highlight doesn't as you can see
highlighted doesn't I wasn't sure that
that and and Nick chose to model under
light it unhighlighted I'm skeptical of
that decision
um
but uh
look this was intended to be used for
things like code assistance
and it's it's mainstreaming the UI for
code assistance
well then that would be an argument for
it evaluating away just like highlighted
because then that means you could you
could actually replace you could modify
a person's notebook you know their
actual input cell to you to have this
without breaking it I agree
it's a good argument for that it
highlighted does it this should do it
too but I'm a little bit confused
over bar is a typesetting construct
you're saying
correct so if you you know if you did if
you did Slash input form on that one
then
right you'd the over bar
yeah and for for the set for that matter
if you did style of Foo comma you know
font variations goes to
um under light goes to red
[Music]
I mean let's just do oops
oh God how do I get back
this is another thing that's just wrong
man I'm in this position I should get
that raft again
command k
no I'm not going to do that I'm going to
complain instead all right well
once you want to continue with the
meeting you can hit command K yeah okay
can you screen cap this case
yep I gotta and make sure that it's
understood for user assistance this is
one of these things that should be
um I mean I don't know that that's
obvious because you know every time you
first or do something having that flash
yeah I understand but don't save that
discussion
Etc okay so this is that and now if I
take this
and I copy this and I use it
it's still there
right and if you change that
strikethrough goes to true to
you know under light goes to Red you'll
have the same behavior
okay
so what's your point so this is now
something
right if you copy that out and use that
as input it will still be there so I'm
just pointing out that you know I
understand how it's still there what is
it still what is that an input form
it's style it's exactly what you typed
in okay
okay
right so I'm just pointing out that
that's a that's a difference between
you know and maybe you'll argue this is
a good difference between underlighted
and just using style but I don't think
we can have this discussion without the
front end folk like John for example I
really don't think it's a good idea
we'll move this tomorrow we'll do this
tomorrow in LCC then okay with John yep
actually just one other quick question
though is is maybe maybe there should be
a generalization of all these you know
highlighted as well where it's it's just
a version of style that goes away when
you evaluate it
like styled or something like this
maybe I I don't know but it seems
there is a way to do that with style
which is if you say strip on input uh
goes to true there's an option to make
style fade away which is strip on input
goes to true
oh but that's probably all you need
because I mean I think this is not
something that I mean this is not a
common
case like this is something where it's
like deep in your weird
code annotation tool is going to use
this so yeah right I use it when I'm
writing low-level make boxes rules I
don't generally use it in uh you know
just typing into a notebook
okay
um
uh let's see can we go on here then
uh what do we have who's relevant for
this we don't have Michael here we don't
have Michael's joining in
okay
okay so what's the issue here
so the issue is in uh Alpha in the
knowledge base we have some entities
have references and basically for every
entity type we have to reinvent a a
different way we don't want to do we
know that right and and and and just to
be very clear is my question we kind of
need Michael for this discussion
he's not joining we should not do that
right now
he should be joining I pinged him he
said to let him know when we were
talking about this let's let's go on and
we'll come back to this okay okay
level map
so this was originally something we
talked about last year uh it was a wolf
from function Repository
submission from Seth Chandler and wheat
said it's effectively an operator form
of map with a level spec
and we had kind of been on the fence
about whether it was something that
warranted being a system function uh in
fact we decided no
is is my recollection of that but then
Seth sent in some additional
items about this okay so
uh okay
the issue here is
would be nice
map thread two
foreign
doesn't thread have a one argument
form I guess not no I'm just saying you
know and map indexed and you know or are
we going to have uh level spec versions
in all the math functions I see
well I mean supplied is a new story for
indexed
and I don't know how supplied works with
operator forms well it has nothing to do
with thread though
by the way
uh
right I mean I think
well I guess there are a couple of
different issues one right because he's
there's one issue of do we want an
operator form of map that takes a level
spec which
is still a bunch of times but whether
this is the right way to do that I'm not
sure or whether what we want to do
instead is to have a you know a
headdress the thing inside map or
something or a headdress for the map
itself
that says uh
you know I mean is there a conceivable
way to headdress the map
to make it
I mean I don't know how successful
things like reverse applied operator
applied things like that I mean I use
them occasionally I have to say I've not
used them as much as I would have liked
to
I mean I think operator applied is very
useful but the syntax can get
complicated you know this again you know
the implementation of map level here
basically uses Curry where it could use
operator applied
but doing it for arbitrary functions can
get
complicated and readability it's
compromised right the the main issue is
you know map F onto blah blah blah
something one wants to do
one also wants to map you know this is
something one wants to do as well
and by the way it's not totally obvious
okay
you know that type of thing and the
question is
come and imagine
doing
you know is can one imagine having
something which is a more compact form
of this without having to create the
explicit Anonymous function
and I don't really see how that works
because you've got to get inside the map
to tell it you're operating at level two
it's not what's wrong with making an
anonymous function I mean
you have to somewhere tell it where the
argument is going to go in
yeah and it's just
it's just one additional character after
that
I mean I I I you know I actually agree
with Christopher on this point but I I
will for for the sake of uh Playing
devil's advocate I suppose that we could
think of you know could imagine
something like leveled or at level or
something which takes two arguments one
of which is an operator form and the
second is
a level spec and you know when you apply
that but I'm not
I'm not sure how General that would be
yeah
the left-hand side right it could say oh
I know this is demand but if you gave it
a generalized function there's nothing
you could do
yeah
but that's already you know
we're playing character counting this is
more characters I can see right and
probably less readable
I mean honestly the only thing that is
awkward about this is the Amazon at the
end but I don't see you know I mean we
could invent yet another notation for
function
well I think there is something we
talked about in one of these meetings a
bit ago which was having a match fix or
whatever you would call it version of
function like some fancy bracket
yes the argument being that that
basically that
I mean really the only reason why it
function you know pure functions are
often a little bit
a little bit annoying is the fact that
they have weird precedence and they they
unavoidably have weird precedence and
even when we make prefix versions of
pure functions they they also have weird
unavoidable precedence
right but if it was match fix it
wouldn't have that
yeah correct
well I think that's a reasonable thing
didn't we we did talk about that before
and we had some ideas for what it might
look like
right uh I I don't remember if this was
I think the issues where we weren't sure
what the ASCII form and I'm not sure we
settled on what the types okay well why
don't we bring back that issue because I
think that's a reasonable thing to
discuss
okay
and I think also we could you know
within that form we could have some nice
uh immediate display for the for the
hash sign which would make it you know I
anyway I think we can do well now right
let's come back to bibliographic
references
um
okay what are the issues here
so the issues are these two sections of
of kind of differing entity types that
handle references in different ways
I mean we already discussed a bunch of
this last time didn't we
well not really because we need to
separate two issues there's there's
citations which is you know a hyperlink
or a little bracket one and then there's
the actual reference which is the thing
that contains the data and wants to be
in some symbolic form that can be
processed and unified across all of the
entities so we want to talk about that
second thing because last time we got
sidetracked by the first thing
hold on so
the issue is
for example
I should be able to give a random
citation from some
that I got from some paper from 1922 or
something in some you know uh you know
not Z Nat
a seven paren 19
14 6 or something and I should be able
to translate that into a beautiful
modern citation
form and do that through an external
service is that correct
yes well I don't know about the external
service but I was thinking we would one
of the ideas that we suggested was
having interpreter
be able to eat a string and return one
of these things
right right
representation of the data right
right but and then given to the there's
two stages there's take the Raw you know
I got this random citation from Place X
turn it into a nice symbolic
representation and there's render our
symbolic representation as a you know
whatever it is APA style reference or
something is that correct right and in
particular as the reference in as what
appears in the bibliography completely
ignoring
hyperlinks uh you know footnotes and
notes right just the complete entry that
would appear hold on hold on hold on
that's a completely separate thing the
question of how things float on pages
and where they get citations inside a
notebook and so on that's completely
separate from that's that's what I'm
saying okay you want to ignore that and
just the thing at you know wherever the
complete data appears that's the
formatting we want to talk about
oh yeah but but okay look to me there is
a function that takes just like export
takes
you know
the the string that is the APA Citation
or whatever they are called
okay
is like an export of the symbolic object
am I making sense I mean it's not the
print form of the symbolic object
probably
it's the export of that to you know
X kind of wacky
citation format
I'm making sense right I think we want
to have an interface like you said the
APA or to Library of Congress or however
we're doing the citations we need that's
going to be a common operation is going
out and alternatively coming in and then
we exactly I think what Ian is trying to
focus on is what the middle layer is
which is our formal symbolic
representation of a citation right I
think it's right but we had a bunch of
things I mean you know there are these
standard things that Librarians talk
about
whether it's you know doubling core or
some of these other things there's a
standard set of fields aren't there
it depends on the reference right like
we had talked about
no there's a standard set of fields that
people fill in and for any given
reference some of those fields might be
blank
yeah for example there might be a field
that says
the location of the thing like if it's a
book that is the unique copy of the you
know the the Gutenberg Bible also no
that that's a printed thing again the um
I know the Rosetta Stone okay how do you
reference the Rosetta Stone
it's a unique thing it's sitting in the
British museum presumably
making sense and that that is a a thing
where most references to books will not
have a location because well the books
can be all sorts of places
um
right so there are
and by the way for the archive system
project that we started it has similar
kinds of things
has similar you know it's there is this
box it might be a physical box that sits
in a particular place it might be a
virtual box
it might uh
in the case of something like that it
might also have various kinds of access
controls
that might be recorded in its record
and so the basic point is there is a
standard set of things that you will put
into one of these records some of them
are more sensible than others
um
uh
you know
look I mean this is the standard thing
the Dublin core you know we know about
this right
oh Dublin okay I I thought you were
saying doubling core and I was very
confused by that but core was being
multiplied by two
I was I'm not familiar with this but
you know right statements provenance
statement there are all kinds of things
here this is a
uh you know it's got all kinds of stuff
right and I could effectively see this
being an animal analogous with what we
have in person data where there's a
superset of properties many of which do
not apply to certain people
yeah but there's you know
there's a somewhat finite set and there
may be you know miscellaneous fields
that can be
I I don't see why we shouldn't just
Define a bunch of things and try and
standardize
um
you know whereas I think uh
let's see all right well what would the
head be what and what would the
structure be just
I don't know this is a good example but
I don't know how many
uh what standard Fields there are are
they how standardized are they author
title whatever
am I making yeah there's 13 publication
types and then a miscellaneous type and
there are keys canonicalize that so
Dublin core I think it's gloppia
mm-hmm
and I think there are some other ones
um
let's see
by the way I think there's some
hairspraying distinction between bib
Tech and Big Bib latex which is the
newer thing
ah
Christopher do you know if they both use
the same
dot bib format or they both have dot bib
files I believe they use different
formats
like they have incompatible files if I
remember right
okay well so
have we studied these I mean
I'm familiar with like APA and MLA
High School basically
I know like in I mean zotero is very
popular it has it's sort of similar that
has a bunch of fields and it has sort of
miscellaneous Fields I think you can add
yeah you can see on the right there
but publication there we go
location and archive
right so I mean presumably what we need
is just a somewhat somebody needs to go
and do the work
of you know inventorying all these
fields we need to have reasonable
canonical names for that
Journal abbreviation
DOI
professional archive
Library catalog call number Etc
right
makes sense
and let's just get a nice list of them
and we'll just get we'll over generate
it and many things will not have most of
them filled out
and then our goal is to be able to go
from a raw textual reference
through either probably mostly an
external API to fill that in or for
example being able to go from a doi to a
filled in
you know citation
makes sense
yep uh
and once we have that
then there's a question of uh
well
I don't know what what so what is that
going to be called the
what what are we going to have as that
object
bibliographic do we not have a name for
that
the things that takes the DOI or
whatever or the
container I'm saying that the the output
thing that is the association of
citation information will that have a
rapper like bibliographic object or
something
I'm suggesting bibliographical reference
for that as the rapper
that's a good name I
think ALS have died with Victorian
period under basic proposal
I think it should just be yeah
bibliographical doesn't feel natural for
me to say at all but I was matching
certain menu items we have that use
bibliographical I wouldn't worry about
it those menu items were created 35
years ago and the you know menu items
are easy to change
yeah
my preference is just bibliographic
right
and I think something you know maybe
this is a discussion we're looking at
citations specifically but that creating
bibliographic references it might be
nice if they were a code assist form for
templates to say I have a book and it
can pre-populate the basic fields that
I'm interested in or I have a journal
article and if we have a thousand
probably not a thousand but somewhere
around 100 potential Keys it might be
nice for there to be some assistance in
populating common ones for common
well that's that's right that is a code
assistance issue okay
you know
I know you said you know these don't
want print forms but I wonder if like we
shouldn't have a second argument which
is you know how to format and then it
does have
I'm kind of thinking about yeah I mean
the way I would see it is if you give
I mean I would say if you said
bibliographic reference
I don't know okay and fizz
foreign
API and try and turn that into its
canonical symbolic form
and then you know and then the other
thing would be that comma
I don't know some some format identifier
that could just be APA or it could be
much like we have date string have a
format identifier a second argument we
could have a form to identifier here
that has certain elements and you could
say put these in this form
does that make some sense I mean just
like
in if I'm not mistaken in date string
you can give it you just list the things
you want
so similarly here you can say yeah list
title blah blah blah blah
and there's some analogy with date
object which can take the same elements
to typeset and it also carries that to
the point where you go to export it so
if you have a date object and say date
format goes to ISO date time it will
print with ISO date time and when you go
to serialize it as a string it will
remember that format
okay so if you were going to you know
typeset bibliographic reference in apa
and then you went to export it and it
said it was tagged as APA it could
default to exporting and whatever the
APA format is versus the MLA versus
Chicago manual style Etc
right
um
okay well do we think we have a plan
here
and okay so we're gonna inventory
possible tags to be used let's write
down what sources are who's using what
etc etc et cetera
um
and uh
then
let's understand I mean I don't know
whether this is going to be an API story
a story of
you know I don't know whether the
converters are accessible from some
other I don't know what zotero I don't
know what it is exactly whether it's a
library we can use Etc
um
we don't want to be coding every one of
these ourselves if we can help it
um
and it might be nice
uh you know we've just done a bunch of
bibliographic citation things
for various things of mine that were
formatted I don't know exactly who 400
of them I think um
Ariana did some page did some not sure
who all has worked on them but those
were I gave a messy reference they
cleaned them up and put them in a
standard format
I'm making sense
yep yeah they'd certainly be good test
cases to look at when we think we have
something that works yeah yeah and we
can look at from the messy reference to
uh I'm not even sure you know those
references I think they were complete
references but just in in totally
scrambled formats and totally
inconsistent formats
um
okay what else do we have to discuss
here Michael do you want to raise some
things
Michael if you're talking we can't hear
you
I'm seeing him on mute and I'm not
hearing anything
um hello hello there okay now we can
hear you don't know what it was okay no
I think that sounds like a good plan
okay so we only need one symbol here
bibliographic reference and we will have
immediate one simple to fill it in
what do you mean by that
what you just said you have the dirty
one and you get a nice one out
right I think well the idea is it's a
self-filling thing you type
bibliographic reference to the dirty
thing and it comes out with a symbolic
thing with a default format
this I think I would not like
what do you want I would also have a
function to do it
because if I have 10 000 of them this
will take weeks
to make the service connect calls
well that's a different issue
I mean
look there's a separate issue which is
to have these in cells in a notebook
and have some Auto some automation that
lets you type them into a cell in a
notebook and say this is a bibliographic
cell and then have it do the right thing
but that that relates to the whole
citation thing on footnoting and so on
I suggest that we try to build this go
ahead but say like if I have an integral
that I don't want to be integrated I
inactivated it feels odd to me to
inactivate a bibliographic reference
just to avoid the table it
well I mean the airplane didn't write
something it cannot even evaluate
could we make it that if it sees an
association it doesn't do anything but
if it sees a string it goes somewhere to
try to populate that Association
sure
once it's an association it's done so to
speak
it's going to assume it's in canonical
form
okay
well you're saying it still needs
activation if if the association is
partially filled out and you want to
fill out dois and things like that in
this Association I think but when all
that says today it is it one's disposure
is that UI and I want the title to be
later
right I wanted to ask is the is the
function that takes a string and gives a
reference a different function from the
thing that takes an external identifier
and returns a reference
I wouldn't have thought so
because presumably with the string you
could you could make something that's a
reference without needing to look up to
see if it's a real reference like if it
kind of looks like it has the proper
form of a reference you could say I
think this is the the author this is the
title I think we have to stop building
this I don't think we know what's going
to happen until we stop building this
and do we know what these service
connect thing is going to be like and so
on
I suggest we stop building it like this
and see what see what it's like
I mean we do have the Crosshair service
connect which probably does everything
that has a UI
okay with real exceptions
okay
but again you know if you say
bibliographic reference of a string that
is a DOI it probably should recognize
that
and you could also give an explicit
external identifier that is a DOI yes
um
okay
all right what else do we have to talk
about here I think we should start
building something here and it would be
good to
at least I mean I think um
uh Bob s
was like several years ago now working
on the archive system and we had a
similar kind of concept there which has
been partially built it will be good to
communicate with him
okay yeah we'll follow up with Bob
the resource system does have Source
metadata which we're just we just have
an association of things like this but
we could integrate something like this
into that as well
how does this relate to the resource
system
because for example we definitely want
a random function repository entry to
have a bibliographic reference
so for example if you give a bibliograph
reference and then you feed it a
resource object it should probably make
the bibliographic reference for the
resource object
does that make sense
yeah we could probably make that right
okay
uh
and similarly if you say bibliographic
reference of a URL it should probably
make a um
uh you know a comma APA or something it
should make the standard kind of um
you know it should make a citation-like
form of the URL now the thing which I
admit is bothering me
is that in some of these cases back to
Michael's point I wouldn't mind storing
in my original document what I
originally typed in for the photographic
reference
do I want that
well I mean look what what the heck why
don't we just put it in the association
the original thing do you understand
what I'm saying have a key that is in
original input or something yeah yeah
yeah
if there's strings there shouldn't be an
issue with that
I don't see a problem with that I mean I
I similar to how there's like an
abbreviated name for the journal and a
full name for a journal
yeah I think the only potential conflict
would be if you have two bibliographic
references that are referencing the same
item but they had different inputs and
you said are they same q but are you
gonna do that yeah I mean I think that
that well okay so that this isn't it
actually that's not such a tough type
situation that's a that's a reasonable
issue because you want to merge them in
a bibliography
that's a reasonable issue
I think we're going to learn a bunch of
these things we actually have to start
building this we're not going to learn
much until we start building it and
start using it
and I am still unclear
whether Michael do you have a thought if
we did have two functions what would
they what would they look like
we even find this normal is doing the
job
of what of turning it into an
association
yep
no no no no not what normal is for eign
there's a high cost action which is
going from the scribbled form to the
canonical form but
and what's an example of a place like
that see I mean
the analog of that that we have is
control equals interpreter
we have like formula lookup for formula
data or two entity for different
canonical forms
well so this might be bibliographic
lookup
[Music]
what's that we also have Dictionary
lookup so there's a button there
but I mean so if we had bibliographic
lookup which would not be a crazy thing
to have
um
I have to say I wonder whether we should
bid it so to speak I mean you know we've
got some other things like Geo where
we're not
I mean I'm kind of wondering if it
should go down to that bibreference
yeah I don't know I mean I don't like
using abbreviations unless they are
standard
um
you know
anyway all right but doesn't that for
now bibliographic lookup then
would go from a raw form
to an inert bibliographic reference
a bibliographic reference will be the
inert object that could be wrapped
in another little graph reference with
the different APA it will be an inert
object like date object as an inert
object
sense
it wouldn't have it wouldn't be doing
the lookup the lookup had already been
done okay the resolution had already
been done
it's strictly a container at that point
it's not a Constructor
right and then but but it is it is a
formatter in the sense that if you yeah
give it you know if you wrap another
bibliographic reference with the
different
format specification it would reformat
itself
just as I assume date object if you wrap
it wrap around it something with a
different date specification it will do
the same kind of thing
yep yeah it'll do conversion
um I'm actually kind of preferring this
because in the case of
you know a raw notebook you can have
something where you say
uh you know you give the source and then
you say bibliographic
um
uh reference
sorry yeah I mean sorry you you give a
source and then you have some actual
action in The Notebook that says go look
up all these bibliographic
sources and convert them to canonical
preferences
right I think we have a path here
um yep and I don't know about a service
connection to zotero
yeah we'll look at the different
services and
see what's reasonable to connect into
fine
okay
uh
I think this could be called biblio
rather than beep
possibly biblio reference
it's removing the graphic like we do in
Geo
[Music]
I see
let's see what is the term for yeah
there's like bibliometrics and so on
yeah so biblio becomes in a very Greek
way
a um a precursor
yeah and it's easier to pronounce than
beep
right
that seems reasonable to me
biblio then becomes the prefix for all
things so biblio look up biblio
reference
seems nice to me
all right I think it's time to move on
here
um
uh good anything else
for right now today nope yeah we'll
revisit the level map stuff when we
think about a general framework for
function markup right sounds good all
right thanks everyone all right see you
later guys okay bye